I was watching a Star Trek on deaeration
ve and jean-luc Picard
and some people product I have some
respect for different ethnicities French
and they go through what do you call it
the Octagon that the rainforests become
younger they turn into kids oh do they
really oh yeah well they still have the
same the only they only go back into
their kid bodies but their brains are
still the same their life experiences
are still there oh wow
and then what happens is O'Brien that
one of the engineers his wife was in it
and she is now a kid but she inside
she's the same there's why the same
person right and what happened she had
cancer
no man no cancer man she's a kid now oh
sorry yeah but she's now they're in
their room right and he feels
uncomfortable so what I'm saying to you
is that and this is a philosophical
debate is is that um it's ila turned
into a kid I'm 12 years old and I'm like
Bobby it's still me but I'm in my 12
year old body yeah yeah I still have
sexual sexuals could your dick even get
how I mean yeah I don't think you can
bro I mean if she's the same girl I'm
sorry you guys a picture of what I look
like when I was 12 it was not cute you
wouldn't [ __ ] me you have a vagina well
my thing is like yeah you know yeah you
know it's tough it's like cuz here's the
thing like I used to like whenever I
would send dick pics to chicks yeah like
I would like I would I didn't want to
send them like my current penis you know
not in order to start somewhere it's
like if you start at the end then you're
at the end all right just started the
beginning sorry I had it the young guy I
happen to have like a bunch of younger
pictures of me when I was naked right so
I would send him like a picture of me at
11 with my [ __ ] dick
right and they're like what the [ __ ] is
this it's like this is like a naked boy
here I'm like yeah that's me you know
like that's my when it was rough
yeah
this is that you know right but by the
third pick most of them don't want to
see the evolution anymore I they just
feel like they feel like dirty people
and then they know a lot of them don't
even talk to me
oh so it's weird this is what she looked
like at 12 come on guys oh my god yeah
you know what I do is I give chick
flicks of my dad's oh oh really show it
to show what its gonna look like
oh my future day I like that right so
and then when they see my actual day
yeah they go oh it's not that bad
Yeah right it's still fresh Yeah right
I like that future future penis that
features our [ __ ] dude they um they have
a app that can show you what your dick
look like in the future yeah no they
don't
yeah they do how it's like future dick
or something dick more dick in the few
oh I know what it is it's probably like
that same aging thing that they do like
time plus dick or some well including my
dad why would I see your dad today when
he was dying guys all right nurse and I
knew that but his dick held up yeah I
mean not I'm not saying that you didn't
go hold up it looked okay yeah didn't
look you know very decrepit or anything
if you watch I watched some weird porn
sometimes sometimes I know and if you
know if you see old women that be trying
to get into that you know and the vagina
like a nine year old woman's vagina it
still relatively looks like a vagina
yeah some some some now I've also seen a
lot of geriatric vagina yeah where they
look like and for Gerry's they call them
yeah sometimes when you have to put like
a catheter in there your ether it takes
a while to - whoa what you can't find
the opening well no because the pinna
sort of collapsed on each other
yeah yeah get into it you just took off
the again you got to peel back the
layers a little bit is a skin is is it I
mean what you can't what you have to
open it up and there's things that grew
over it okay not you don't get extra
skin growing on yeah yeah this skin just
loses its elasticity over the years you
know why okay I'm gonna tell you
something right now the reason why old
warning it's not like that is because
they're using it but like anything I'm
sure you know a girl that's a virgin at
25 it looks like that to them now I've
also seen older women with very nice
vagina so I think it's no it's what how
they use it if it's a if you give you
any any tool that you don't use if you
go to an old factory yeah you go to you
know Detroit you go to an old car
factory that's been like not in use for
20 years things lost yeah yeah I think
you know but you got a oil it up get the
index roller you got a grease that thing
resting that damn thing up so it's not a
little but polish on that thing right so
if you look at like you know Whoopi
Goldberg's vagina right if she's using
it I bet it's more Goldberg than Whoopi
seems aggravated yeah yeah yeah yeah but
I'm sure if she uses it it looks fine
[Music]